hi there it's Kevin Van Ord standing in
for review earn it Kappa solely to tell
you about
fracked OSC video games are uniquely
suited to placing users inside an
imaginary space that's a notion that
Tron took quite literally and fracked
osce doesn't stray far from the same
idea in fracked you find yourself within
a synthesizer full of floating geometry
and backlit monoliths the first sight
you see in fracked is awash in black
though in first-person view you fumble
your way over to a darkened computer
terminal only to find it locked the
synthesizer is broken split into a trio
of color-coded components that need to
be reconstructed afterwards the area
branches outward into layered networks
of caves and puzzle rooms each
components puzzle comes in two flavors a
generalized brain teaser and a musically
inclined variant when solved the puzzles
fill their immediate environment with
house music and unlock corresponding
portions of the larger instrument back
at its terminal since fracked doesn't
offer much in the way of direction
you're left to wander the games tunnels
in search of promising landmarks
thankfully the game's organic sometimes
mechanical scenery holds quite a few of
them it's an impressive labyrinth and
you gain a better appreciation for its
complexity when you take a ride on the
fast travel model rails that link it all
together but just off the beaten path
you'll find ugly areas and dead ends and
because fracked is so directionless you
end up spending too much time within
them all that time wandering might be
less tedious if you could kick back with
some engaging songs but fracked is
surprisingly quiet for a game about
music the exception comes when you're
putting the finishing touches on one of
the musical puzzles which usually
involve laying down a set of tones and a
repeating musical measure successfully
integrating your portion of the song
causes additional and
means to come crashing into the music
resulting cavalcade of sounds makes for
a wonderful reward enjoyable as the
puzzles are they're overshadowed by
those that don't seem he matically
relevant to the game setting fracked is
overstuffed with platforms that need
raising sliders that need switching and
tumblers that need rotating most of
these puzzles are uninteresting and
they're further hampered by the game's
movement quirks confusingly gaps between
platforms can sometimes be walked over
but once in a while you'll plummet
through a small crack in the upper
floors of a puzzle and will have to make
your way all the way back up from the
bottom eventually you find yourself back
at the main synthesizer and stare at the
glowing dials something's lost in
translation here when you feel like a
partner to the game's music making
fracks lets you get lost in the beat
unfortunately the bland environmental
puzzles lack and engaging rhythm
you